a local family is grieving tonight after
a 30-year-old man was stabbed and killed
in an alley in the Central Valley thanks
for joining us at 11 I'm Denise Valdez
and I'm Brian Loftus they say he was on
his way home about one in the morning
last Saturday when he was attacked near
Maryland Parkway and Desert Inn Sasha
Loftus spoke with his mother she joins
us live for Metro Police Headquarters
with this story you'll only see on 8
News Now
connection with this crime is in police
custody tonight now those who knew
Marcos Anthony Roca say that he was a
wonderful person and he didn't deserve
to die so young
[Music]
you know always trying to get everybody
to start dancing he was known for the
light he brought to life
Marcos Anthony Roca a father a son a
friend he was just a good kid with a
good heart he helped everybody but last
week that was suddenly stolen when
police say Roca was stabbed and killed
here in this alley near Maryland Parkway
and Desert Inn I need to know is the why
why kill him his mother Martha Santos
tells us he was on the way home from a
friend's house when he was attacked his
phone and wallet taken records show a
suspect was arrested days later and is
now in police custody this person that
did this to my son has no idea what he
took away from us as she and everyone
who loved Marcos tried to come to terms
with their Grace that to me was reality
when they asked me in what casket did I
want for my son at age 30. they're also
doing their best to demand Justice and
remember everything he was he saw
somebody out there he would give him you
know his last five dollars if he had to
along with the happiness he brought to
those who were able to know him the pain
is unbearable
now the man arrested in connection with
this case Joshua Billings faces a murder
charge he's due back in court on the
13th now there is also a GoFundMe to
help the family with funeral expenses if
you would like to help out reporting
live tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now